hello and welcome to the daily climate
show from koblent in
germany as floods devastate parts of
western europe
more than a hundred people dead and over
a thousand missing as communities in
both
germany and belgium are warned they're
still in danger
[Music]
as rescue efforts continue already the
focus turns to whether the climate
crisis is to blame
i'll be speaking to one of the world's
leading experts in
weather and climate
and the environmental campaigner known
as the german greta
tells sky news governments around the
world need to take
drastic measures to tackle the climate
crisis
[Music]
hello and welcome to this special
edition of the daily climate show
i'm in koblenz on the banks of the rhine
and the mosul rivers
in western germany an area badly
affected
by the extreme weather that's hit much
of western europe
over a hundred people have died and many
more are missing
and even as the scale of the tragedy
emerges
more rain is forecast for today and the
weekend
on today's show we'll be examining the
theories around the increasing extreme
weather events
and ask how prepared we are for them and
we'll speak to louisa
neubauer often referred to as the german
greta tunberg but first let's remind
ourselves of the terrible images
that were the result of two months of
rain in just over
two days
this is short in western germany one of
the worst hit villages
several homes collapsed due to flooding
after the river there
surged into a deadly torrent carrying
trees and other debris
as it gushed through the narrow streets
in belgium flood waters rushed through
the streets of pepinster
after the vesdre river spilled over its
banks
and there were similar scenes in the
village of ross pour in luxembourg where
flooding left
caravans and football stadiums submerged
so that's an idea of the damage caused
let's take a look now at the situation
right across europe while flooding has
hit multiple
countries including the uk germany
belgium luxembourg
and the netherlands germany's most
populous states
north rhine westphalia has been badly
affected
with 148 liters of rain per square meter
within 48 hours
in a part of the country that usually
sees about 80 liters in the whole
of july a dam close to the belgium
border the
rootless spare was flooded overnight
while in the reinsee county south of
cologne several villages below the
steinbach reservoir
were evacuated over fears a dam could
break there
one of the worst affected areas is the
state of rhineland palatinate
including the mountainous district of
avila
where many are thought to have died in
flash floods on thursday
among the villages hit hardest there is
schultz
several homes collapsed and dozens of
people remain
unaccounted for and across the border
in belgium the cities of neymar and
liege have been evacuated as
the river muse bursts its banks
our climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter
joins me now from liege hannah what's
the situation like
where you are we've moved just outside
that city to a village called pepinster
which is
really a village completely upended
built at the confluence of two rivers
because of course that was useful for
moving trade
and goods and totally vulnerable when
the waters
came and the cleanup is ongoing but
we've spoken to many residents here who
are in
absolutely no doubt that climate change
has had a hand
in their destruction to their
livelihoods and property
speakers
a
we've also interviewed one of the lead
authors for a report by the ipcc the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change the un body
who happens to be a resident of belgium
who told us that
he was completely shocked that his
hometown of liege would
become a cautionary tale an example of
how climate change is coming
to the western world and he said that we
have to understand that although
it's very difficult to link directly and
definitively
climate change with one particular
extreme
event climate change is much uh is
driving the issue making it much more
likely and much more frequent much more
likely that the
weather events are going to be extreme
this is what he had to say to us
about the link between the two things
there will be
no return to the climate that we used to
know some 20 or 30 years ago
the temperature will not decrease the
sea level
will not decrease and there will be no
vaccine against climate change
we need to consider and to accept that
this is the new normality that this is
the new reality
that we have to adapt to now the
question really for villagers
like pepinster and towns and cities all
over western europe is
is about the future if western europe is
going to see
more of this extreme weather it's really
about
adaption about how we build where we
build what materials we use which
which places we put our towns and
villages how we better protect
our businesses and livelihoods and
critical
infrastructure all of that being
considered now by the people who live
here
who've lost so much so that's the
situation
in belgium my europe correspondent
michelle clifford has the latest from
germany and the village of olof in the
state of north rhine westphalia
like thousands across this region
presidents of the village of olof are
absolutely stunned by what's happened
they were shocked
by the scale of the flooding terrified
by the sheer ferocity of the water
it tore into houses ripped off doors
ripped up
pavings and roadways one man told us if
anyone had been in his house on the
evening of the floods
they would have been killed and asked
people here as we have done
why they think this has happened and
they say simply climate change that the
weather
and the world is changing and there are
growing worries today
there's a reservoir nearby and real
fears that it will
fail and could consume three villages
nearby
michelle clifford there in the village
of olof so
what's behind this extreme weather
well eu commission president ursula
vonderlaan said the flooding
is a clear indication of climate change
and that's a view shared by
many scientists who say although it's
hard to attribute
individual weather events to climate
change their frequency
and severity is increasing but land
management could also be a factor
for example the river rhine has already
lost four-fifths of its natural flood
plains
and urbanization can increase flood risk
too more impermeable hard surfaces
prevent rain from
infiltrating into the soil below the
increased run-off can create significant
flood risk
with even moderate rainfall and the
situation
is only expected to worsen as a changing
climate
triggers more extreme rainfall
events but the immediate cause
is this an area of low pressure became
stuck over parts of europe
bringing a near stationary zone of heavy
and continuous rain to western germany
the low pressure system is not moving
because it's being held in place
by areas of high pressure elsewhere in
europe
over two months worth of rain has fallen
in the space of two days
in the areas affected by flooding well
joining me to explain if these
devastating floods
can be linked to climate change is
professor brian hoskins chair of the
grantham institute
at imperial college london and professor
of meteorology
at the university of reading really
great to have you
on the programme thanks for being with
us we keep being told don't we that we
shouldn't necessarily
link individual weather events to
climate change but what do you make
of what we're seeing right now in europe
i think it is really a warning to us and
these sorts of events
could possibly happen without us having
added greenhouse gases to the atmosphere
and global warming of a degree or more
but they become much more likely with
the warming that we've done
and it's a very strong effect because
the atmosphere
if it's six degrees warmer can hold
fifty percent more water
so the same rainstorm without anything
else being different
would be fifty percent stronger now it
seems to be happening even at a more
rapid rate than that would suggest
is it now a fact of life that we just
have to expect
more of these extreme weather events
yes it is um the heat wave in north
america
the cause of that well it's partly
because there it's been so dry so what
we expect with climate change
is more of the droughts and more of the
heavy rainfall and when it's been very
dry
then the sun's energy instead of
evaporating water
goes to heat up the air so that was a
major contributor
to the heat wave over north america
which wasn't just a degree or so above
previous records
it was five degrees above previous
records so the sort of heat waves there
and the floods we've seen
around the world and they're not so long
ago a few weeks ago there were
major storms in japan causing mudslides
and
loss of life and now we have this in
europe so we're really getting these
warnings from the climate system
it's telling us my goodness you better
do something because
this is only going to get worse
okay really good to get your thoughts we
appreciate your time thank you
you're very welcome
now on our data dashboard you can see
how much our planet has warmed
since the industrial revolution and it's
ticking up
the whole time but as an industrialized
country germany
is heating up twice as fast as the
global warming rate
meaning an increased chance of heavy
rainfall now compared to before
the industrial revolution it is one of
the reasons environmental groups
took the german government to court
recently saying its climate targets were
insufficient
to protect future generations in a
groundbreaking ruling the court agreed
saying politicians must update the
legislation
to ensure emissions goals are met
well among the activists who lobbied for
change was louisa
noy bauer anna jones spoke to her
earlier
first of all angela merkel has called
for a determined battle
against climate change you recently won
a case against the german government so
what
more do you think needs to be done now
well we need more than words and
that's it we see how chancellor merkel
and also other
members of the government are really
happy and enthusiastic when it comes to
talking about what they want to do um in
order to protect us from the climate
breakdown
yet when it comes to action we see that
effectively the government
is working towards a three four five
degree warmer world
instead of sticking to 1.5 degree
pledges
well we need of course drastic measures
happening now this
must include a rapid um coal phase out
not stretched until 2038 which would be
the current plan of the government
but really making sure that there won't
be any coal power plants in germany
running after 2030
we need an em we need a stop of new
fossil fuel infrastructure that must
include for instance the new gas
pipeline north stream two that is
currently
um in under construction we need to
think about um
if we need new um large roads
um if they should be built at all how do
we get more people away
from um combustion engine towards um
electrification on the streets and so on
so there are million things that need to
be done
there are great plans provided by think
tents and economists and other
institutions
and it's time for the government really
to listen to the science there
and if scientists do attribute
definitively
the severity of these floods to climate
change when they've got all the evidence
in the weeks ahead
how might that affect public opinion but
also political will there do you think
well we would hope that people wouldn't
have to be dying and floods for our
government to acknowledge that we are in
a climate breakdown
and but if it takes those floods it
would be then
time of course for drastic critical
measures um
we are not hopeful at all about this
because we see
how um well
how resilient the government is when it
comes to acknowledging the climate
crisis we are in
um but yes of course we will um
pressure them for um drastic measures
for political consequences
coming and from these catastrophes
louisiana thanks very much indeed
thank you so much louisa now bower
speaking to anna jones there well just
before we go
let me explain that exactly where we are
we're in the town of kublenz in germany
and as you can see we're next to the
river here this is the river
mosul the rhine is just around the
corner now normally at this time
of year flooding really wouldn't be
expected but as you can see
it's well and truly broken the banks
it's covered the pavement
next to the water and it's covered this
road as well it's lapping
up against the the borders of the town
and we've spoken to
a number of businesses who are flooded a
cafe a restaurant just here
basement completely flooded they've got
the pumps going they say that
occasionally
flooding does happen but this is
something else
all together and what's particularly
worrying for everyone here and in the
wider region is that more rain
is forecast for later today and over the
weekend we will of course keep you up to
date
on sky news and you can keep up to date
with all the latest developments
on this moving story as well as the
day's other climate news on the sky news
website just go to
sky news dot com forward slash climate
and that's all from us this week but a
reminder you can listen to our podcast
over the weekend
in the latest episode of climate cast we
explore the role
education and family planning can play
in the fight against climate change
you can find that's wherever you
normally get your podcasts
from plus
you can watch our weekly climate show on
sky news social channels our app
and website in this episode the story of
the 69 year old grandpa
turning indonesia's mountains green
well thanks for watching anna jones
we'll be back
next week
[Music]